nvidia is one of the most underrated
mega cap companies in the world while
nvidia is extremely popular within
gaming and tech circles the average
person is not so familiar with the
company
this is quite surprising because unlike
some other background mega cap companies
like tsmca and asml much of nvidia's
customer base is everyday people
despite this nvidia was able to race
towards a trillion-dollar evaluation
under the radar and at that peak nvidia
boasted a valuation of 867 billion
dollars
but it looks like becoming a trillion
dollar company it just wasn't in the
cards for nvidia at the time given that
the stock has gotten obliterated
in fact since their peak in november
nvidia has sold off a painful 55 which
correlates to a market cap loss of 480
billion dollars by now this is probably
not even that surprising and given how
bad the overall market is doing but like
all the other companies that have sold
off this much nvidia does have its own
set of shortfalls and concerns so here's
why nvidia is down 480 billion dollars
and why it may be a long journey back to
the top
one of the biggest shortfalls of
nvidia's business is that they've
somehow become a seasonal business
now this might sound a bit surprising
given that demand for gpus is rather
constant from companies and everyday
people but there's also a third
demographic that you need to consider
which is of course miners if you're not
familiar with cryptocurrency mining it's
basically a super computational intense
process that validates crypto
transactions the people who validate
these transactions are called miners and
they get paid for each block of
transactions that they validate miners
don't have to do anything manually but
given the high computational
requirements to mine they're forced to
buy extremely powerful hardware and as
you would guess one of their top choices
is nvidia gpus
in the early days miners didn't really
influence the overall gpu market all
that much as they were a pretty small
community but as cryptocurrency becomes
larger and the more people jump on board
it's only natural that the mining
community has also gotten quite large if
miners were simply buying gpus on a
regular basis this wouldn't really be a
problem
but the interest in mining is highly
correlated with the bitcoin market
cycles which have thus far been highly
seasonal for example let's take a look
at the 2017 bitcoin cycle and compare it
to nvidia's net income as we can see
ethereum which is what people were
predominantly mining with nvidia gpus
peaked in early 2018. some lasting
momentum along with the release of
nvidia's 2000 series of gpus carried the
company throughout much of 2018 but as
the hype surrounding the new gpu settled
down and miners flocked the scene
nvidia's net income got obliterated
within just two quarters nvidia's net
income crashed 68 percent from 1.23
billion dollars to 394 million dollars
it was until the last quarter of 2020
when bitcoin returned to its all-time
high the nvidia's net income also
recovered since then nvidia's income has
only gone up but as we saw in 2018 it
takes about a year for the cryptocycle
to reflect an nvidia's bottom line
also nvidia is supposed to release the
4000 series of gpus this year similar to
2000 series in 2018
so that should help hold up your income
for some time but as we get into the end
of this year and especially the
beginning of next year the weak crypto
market will likely weigh down on
nvidia's income quite substantially
even if crypto markets do recover within
the next 12 months it's going to be
difficult for nvidia to maintain their
current numbers because nvidia and
miners are slowly parting ways from
nvidia side they've been limiting the
performance of their gpus if they're
used for mining the goal with this limit
is to mitigate the demand from miners
and make more gpus available for
everyone else now of course hackers have
figured out a way to bypass these limits
but that's besides the point the point
is that nvidia is finally taking action
to limit the number of gpus that are
sold to miners
this was something that nvidia was
previously extremely reluctant to do for
obvious reasons however nvidia has been
switching their stands likely because
they realize that in the long term they
will lose the mind demographic no matter
what and when that happens they want to
ensure that they have a strong core of
gamers that are still loyal to their
brand but wait a minute why will nvidia
lose out on a mining demographic in the
first place well the answer boils down
to two reasons starting with asics
basics or application specific
integrated circuits are hardware that
are specifically built for a given
computational purpose which in our case
is mining in the early days mining asics
weren't that prevalent given that there
wasn't much demand for them but nowadays
flaunt companies like bitmain have been
built on just selling mining asics and
given that mining asics are specifically
built for mining they're way better than
nvidia's gaming gpus for mining now
nvidia has launched their own mining
specific hardware so they might make a
targeted move in the crypto market but
the days of using gaming gpus for mining
are definitely coming to an end
something else to consider is that much
of the crypto market is trying to move
away from mining altogether due to how
wasteful the process is
after all in mind you have to buy loads
of expensive hardware and constantly
burn mounds of electricity to keep them
running so cryptos like ethereum are
trying to switch to a proof of stake
model from a proof of work model both of
these models are rather complex to
explain but all you need to know is that
the new method does not require super
powerful hardware the founder of
ethereum vitalik buterin has already
been trying to make the switch for years
and he may be trying for years to come
as well
but at this point it seems like a
transition to proof-of-stake not just
for ethereum but cryptocurrencies as a
whole is inevitable and as crypto and
nvidia severed their ties there's no
question that nvidia's financials will
take a hit now it might seem like i'm
overstating nvidia's dependence on
mining but this is not the case in fact
the sec justified nvidia for not
disclosing how dependent they were on
crypto mining to investors considering
this declining demand from miners is by
far the biggest short-term threat for
nvidia
another major threat for nvidia's
business is through unsustainable price
increases over the past several years
nvidia has enjoyed extremely strong
pricing power due to overwhelming demand
for one miners are willing to pay way
more for nvidia's gpus than gamers
because it's an investment for them not
just entertainment and secondly the
supply shortage and more specifically
the chip shortage has made it impossible
for nvidia to keep up with the demand
this deadly combination has led to gpu
selling for unreal amounts on secondary
markets take the rtx 3090 for example
the rtx 3090 launched with a sticker
price of fifteen hundred dollars this
itself is super expensive until you take
a look at how much his gpus are selling
for all on secondary markets
this listing for example comes in at an
eye watering of four thousand eight
hundred dollars or over three times the
launch price now given that this is the
resale market nvidia doesn't actually
make anything from these ludicrous
resale prices however this has allowed
nvidia to substantially raise the launch
prices of their new gpus for example in
2017 nvidia's flagship gpu the gtx 1080
ti launched for 700
last year nvidia launched the 3000
series equivalent the 3080ti for 1200
this means that nvidia was able to raise
prices by 71 within a matter of four
years and that that's not even
considering their new additions you see
it nvidia had so much demand that they
decided to launch even higher end
consumer gpus called the 3090 and 3090
ti and the launch price of the 3090 ti
is a whopping two thousand dollars this
means that nvidia's flagship consumer
gpu has risen from seven hundred dollars
to two thousand dollars within five
years
clearly gpu prices have gotten way out
of hand and they've been like this for
years this point but eventually things
will cool down like they always do and
nvidia will lose pricing power i mean
even apple had reduced the launch price
of their iphones with the iphone 11 and
apple had only raised the launch price
of their iphone by 100
nvidia is over here raising prices by
500
so it's no wonder that investors are
worried about nvidia's pricing power in
the future
it's not just nvidia's customers that
have been willing to pay any price for
their gpus till recently nvidia's
investors were also willing to pay any
price for nvidia stock in fact i don't
think it's a stretch to say that nvidia
had the rigid valuation on the entire
stock market for example if we take a
look at their pe ratio or their price to
earnings ratio they were floating at 70
to 80 for months of 2020 and 2021. for
perspective apple is trading at a pe
ratio in the mid-20s and microsoft is
trading at a pe ratio in the high 20s
now this is not actually that bad when
you compare it to tesla which peaked at
a pe ratio of over one thousand tesla
was barely profitable with the net
margin of 2.29
while nvidia was at peak profitability
within that margin of over 30
this means that tesla's pe ratio was
super skewed due to low profits while
nvidia's p ratio wasn't skewed at all
and this becomes super clear when we
compared the price to sales ratios of
the two companies tesla's ps ratio
peaked at 23.75 while in video sps ratio
ran all the way to 26.62
also let's not forget that tesla is the
most hyped stock on the market but
somehow nvidia was even more richly
valued despite having far inferior
growth prospects also the recent
sell-off hasn't made their valuation
that much better nvidia still has a pe
ratio of nearly 50 and a market cap of
460 billion dollars and thus far nvidia
has only been reporting stellar quarters
imagine if nvidia has just one quarter
of stagnation or even a decline their
current valuation would just become even
less justified causing investors to sell
off the stock even further and don't
think that just because nvidia has
already dropped 50 means that they can't
drop much further because they
definitely can if mining demand doesn't
recover and the overall market continues
to sell off nvidia can easily crash 80
to 90 percent like it did during the dot
com bust and the 2000 financial
recession really you don't even have to
look that far to realize how much nvidia
can drop just take a look at netflix or
paypal right now
at the end of the day nvidia has been
popped up by several factors for several
years now
first you have the 2017 bitcoin board on
it then there was a 2021 bitcoin forward
on it and now you have a supply shortage
all of these factors have given nvidia
an unprecedented amount of pricing power
and leverage which nvidia has cleverly
used to maximize profits
but as these temporary boosts start to
fade away the short-term future of
nvidia is becoming more and more
uncertain combine this with the fact
that nvidia already had one of the rigid
valuations on the market and it becomes
clear that nvidia's 50 sell-off could it
just be the beginning of something much
more painful
this isn't to say that nvidia is screwed
in the long term by any means though
nvidia produces the best gpus in the
world and they diversified it into
several sectors from machine learning to
artificial intelligence so nvidia is by
no means going anywhere but it's very
likely that we start to see declines in
nvidia's financials as the gpu market
finally cools down and miners move away
from gaming gpus
but if we look past that i think it's
just a matter of time until their
dominant position and massive
investments pay off and nvidia reaches a
trillion dollar valuation but that's
just what i think do you guys have an
nvidia gpu comment that down below also
drop a like if you can't wait for gpu
prices to finally cool down and of
course consider checking out our
international channels to watch your
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one